welcome to the show let's get right into
it I've been waiting since the third
democratic debate last Thursday to get
some post debate polling yesterday early
we got one post debate poll but one is
just one alas and I wanted to wait until
we had at least a second post debate
poll and we now have that so we're going
to be able to look at them in detail
let's sort of refresh the backstory the
backstory of course being that basically
since even before he formally announced
his candidacy I think it was an April
former vice-president Joe Biden has been
leading the polls we've seen Bernie
Sanders in second place for quite some
time but one of the storylines of
polling for the last several months has
been that as Joe Biden sort of drops off
from what was a round of 44 ish percent
high at one point months ago it has been
Elizabeth Warren who has been sort of
steadily picking up one to one and a
half points every single month with
Bernie Sanders basically remaining in
this second place spot and that has been
shaken up now I think at this point we
have to say that there is a different
paradigm which is that the momentum has
shifted behind Elizabeth Warren I can't
think of another candidate who is even
remotely in this thing who has the
momentum of Elizabeth Warren right now
so let's take a look first at what the
polls look like in general you'll notice
if you're watching along with me the
Green Line at the top going above 40%
several months ago is Joe Biden and Joe
Biden has had his ups and downs now
settling at an average of 27 in recent
polls and still in first place for now
the second line on this graph has been
Bernie Sanders and as you can see Bernie
Sanders steadily in second place for
many many months although you have seen
a sort of convergence of the brown line
which is Elizabeth Warren who is polling
right around 6% months ago
slowly but steadily climbing climbing
climbing and now actually jumping into
second place statistically in an average
of recent polls ahead of Bernie Sanders
eighteen point three to sixteen point
three this is of course an average of
recent polls now some
important caveats 18.3 versus 16.3 is
not some massive gulf we could get one
more post third debate poll and this
could completely reverse itself and
Bernie Sanders could be exactly tied
with Warren or ahead these are general
numbers that give us a sense of the
momentum now even more important
arguably in terms of the number of polls
if you look right now at the last 10
polls or the last 12 polls or the last
14 polls what you will see is that in
half of them Bernie Sanders is in second
place in half of them Elizabeth Warren
is in second place recency is weighted
slightly more in these averages of
recent polling Xand there is one
particular recent poll in which
Elizabeth Warren is solidly in second
place that's where this average comes
from so now that we've seen this trend
line of Elizabeth Warren climbing with
Bernie Sanders sort of holding steady
and again please don't shoot the
messenger I hope that we're beyond the
point of making personal attacks on me
merely for reporting to you what it is
that the polls say as many of you know
I'm a Bernie Warren guy I think that
there are upsides to both of them I
think that together they are a very
strong progressive sort of duo in the
Democratic primary this is we're just
talking about the polls don't kill the
messenger okay and by the way if you're
gonna write to me and say the polls are
only polling old people on landlines we
debunk that multiple times that's not
true let's really keep the conversation
productive rather than resorting to this
stuff so we have to post debate data
points right now the debate was last
Thursday we have two polls that were
conducted after that debate the first is
the Politico morning consult poll this
is the poll in which Bernie Sanders is
still in second place Joe Biden 32
Bernie Sanders 20 Elizabeth Warren 18
Bernie and Warren statistically tied but
Bernie Sanders ahead 20 to 18 you'll
also notice that we still have seen no
changes anywhere else to suggest that
anybody other than Biden Sanders and
Warren even remotely have a shot at this
thing Kamala Harris you despite some
people on my Twitter telling me she
obviously won the debate
nothing happening she's still at 6%
Buddha judge at 5:00
Beto may be gaining a little bit up to
4% Booker and yang both at 3 and clova
char at 2 so that is one of the two
post-debate polls this one has a
statistical tie between Bernie and
Warren with Bernie ahead by 2 the second
post debate poll that we have is an NBC
news/wall Street Journal poll and this
is the one that has Elizabeth Warren
very solidly in second place 25 to
Bernie Sanders 14 with Biden still in
first place with 31 now I do find it
difficult to believe that Bernie Sanders
is polling only 14 percent nationally
given everything else that we've seen
recently but and again I'm just the
messenger
I'm just the analyst I like Bernie I it
sucks that I have to do these
disclaimers but they do help to mitigate
a little bit of the crazy messages I get
there are actually now several recent
polls which have Bernie near 14 the hill
last week had him at 15 The Economist
had him at 16 Reuters had him at 16 and
after the debate the third debate last
week I actually got a ton of emails from
people saying David I like Bernie but I
think that he's done and some
attributing it to the stagnant poll
numbers relative to Elizabeth Warren's
momentum a lot of people emailing me
saying you know Bernie certainly didn't
help himself with his voice being horse
for the first half of the debate
combined with Elizabeth Warren getting
to do rebuttals before Bernie almost
every time since their views were very
similar in terms of the content of their
rebuttals Bernie came off as if he was
just saying me to to war and merely
because they went to her first for
rebuttals but more people than we've had
in the last six months contacting me
saying Bernie is done and I hope that
that's not the case I I don't believe
Bernie has done from any objective point
of view at this point in time but
anybody who's looking at the polling has
to realize that the momentum is with
Elizabeth Warren and if you look at
recent polls if you look at the same
polls over the last four months you will
notice that Joe Biden
has on average lost a little bit Bernie
Sanders is roughly even to have lost a
little bit and Elizabeth Warren has just
been steadily gaining one to one and a
half points a month so momentum
undoubtedly with Elizabeth Warren now
the conversation I want to have with you
soon is about Bernie versus Warren
putting aside our personal feelings
about things like who do we like better
personality-wise putting aside even
everything but thinking objectively
about the pragmatics of their platform
there is the idea which I'm reading
about more and more that while Elizabeth
Warren is certainly more moderate than
Bernie Sanders even though particularly
domestically their policies are similar
I'm starting to sing more and more is
starting to see more and more opinions
that Elizabeth Warren may be more
effective as president in that her ideas
are more likely to be able to be made
effective via law policy or executive
order than those of Bernie Sanders now
that's a very general statement I think
if we really want to deal with that
seriously we have to look at okay let's
look at healthcare Bernie versus Warren
why specifically if we are making the
case that Warren's plan is more likely
to be made a reality than Bernie's why
is it that we're saying that when it
comes to inequality what specifically
about Elizabeth Warren's plan versus
Bernie's is more likely to become a
reality so the question is even if we
are more progressive let's say and we
find Bernie to be more progressive than
Warren and I believe in a marginal sense
he is is there a way in which effective
progress may be higher with Elizabeth
Warren because she may be more likely to
get you know a few Republicans on board
or whatever the case may be I am merely
asking the question I am not telling you
that that's the case it's a pretty
classic pragmatism versus idealism
conversation but sometimes when people
say idealism there's like a negative
connotation attached to it or some kind
of dismissive element
I love Bernie's ideas so when I say
idealism what I mean is the ideas are
great ideas and completely not
controversial in many
parts of the world that seemed to have
things figured out in Northern Europe
and elsewhere it's merely a practical
question and we're gonna be dealing with
this soon but before I deal with it I
want to hear from you about it let me
know your thoughts on that in terms of
the practicality and potential for
really effecting change with president
Bernie versus President Warren